[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le
grand jt des territoires laissez moi
tout d'abord vous souhaiter une
excellente année à tous et à toutes de
la part de toute l'équipe du grand jt
des territoires que cette année soit
belle et heureuse pour chacun de vous
ouverte malgré tout nous partons dans
les vosges maintenant où la station de
ski de gérardmer la mauselaine a ouvert
ses portes en proposant diverses
activités
mais évidemment pas de ski alpin faute
de pouvoir faire fonctionner les
remontées mécaniques vous le savez sur
décision gouvernementale
les premières réactions avec ce
reportage des équipes de via vosges sur
place dans la neige la neige est là il
comptait bien en profiter ce week end à
la station de la mauselaine à gérardmer
pour une ouverture exceptionnelle
exceptionnelle car de telles conditions
d'enneigement précoce ne se présente pas
tous les ans mais surtout parce que les
remontées mécaniques sont à l'arrêt sur
décision gouvernementale pas de ski
alpin donc mais dutreil le des raquettes
du ski de randonnée et bien sûr de la
luge
c'est simplement le pur plaisir plaisir
d'aller faire du ski de rando juste
après et d'emmener ma petite nièce
profiter des plaisirs de la neige mais
du coup c'est l'occasion de découvrir de
nouveaux sports
hier j'ai fait un peu de ski de fond
j'ai jamais fait donc ça sort un peu
aussi de nos sentiers battus nous on a
juste à attendre a finalement dans une
bonne situation n'est qu'aux clients
mais surtout pour les professionnels
c'est compliqué d'autant plus frustrant
pour les professionnels que l'hiver
dernier avait été compliqué d'un point
de vue météo et déjà écourté par lakovic
les conditions en ce début décembre sont
idéales et le domaine géromois 120
salariés lors de son pic d'activité
aurait pu être ouverts dans sa
quasi-totalité dès ce week-end pour
l'instant qu'on prend notre mal en
patience en
on continue à préparer les pistes en a
mis en place des bouées sur neige sur la
petite madeleine des activités de l'usch
sécurisé pour limiter les accidents et
limiter l'engorgement des hôpitaux en
est bien conscient de la situation selon
les saisons décembre peut représenter de
10 à 20% du chiffre d'affaires annuel
jusqu'à 25% pour les moniteurs de
l'école du ski français
ils sont soixante dix à gérardmer et
seulement 6 à travailler actuellement
entre la mauselaine et les bas rupts la
décision concernant les remontées
mécaniques sera réévalué le 11 décembre
dans le cadre d'une clause de revoyure
autre échéance très attendue plus
généralement pour les professionnels du
tourisme la levée des restrictions de
déplacement fixée normalement au 15
décembre les fata ça s'annonce un peu à
peu compliqué mais on a quand même des
taux de réservation qui augmente un tout
petit peu la première semaine nous on
doit être à peu près à 60 % et la
deuxième semaine à 70% sur les locations
saisonnières
en attendant les prochaines annonces
gouvernementales la station de la
mauselaine à gérardmer sera ouverte dans
les mêmes conditions les mercredis
samedis et dimanches sachant que les
licenciés mineurs sportifs de haut
niveau et professionnels peuvent accéder
aux remontées mécaniques dans la vallée
du gier
chez françois colombes et l'ambiance est
magique des milliers de lumières
remplisse son jardin et la façade de sa
maison
les voisins en prennent plein les yeux
plein les mirettes comme on dit dans nos
régions et les visiteurs viennent
parfois de très loin
cécilia hairsine à elisa moulin pour la
chaîne t elle cette télé loire 7 sur
place regarder
sa récompense françois que l'on bella
trouve dans le regard émerveillé des
enfants
magique à travers un parcours les
visiteurs peuvent découvrir le travail
de françois colombes et des kilomètres
de guirlandes des milliers dans pool le
spectacle est fascinant et chacun est
différent est émerveillé d'année en
année c'est de plus en plus beau et puis
voilà ça et puis en ce moment en plus je
crois que on a besoin de tout ça toutes
ces lumières nous enchante
c'est très joli comme toutes les années
c'est pour ça qu'on revient toutes les
années c'est vraiment très très beau moi
j'aime bien tout ce qui est la lumière
en vente libre il allège coup ça fait
très joli mais difficile de trouver
l'artiste pour le féliciter
françois colombet est un homme discret
qui observent de loin les sourires de
ces visiteurs c'est une passion une
passion celle là j'aime tellement faire
plaisir on verra on a des gens qui
viennent de l'autre bout du département
pour voir votre maison mais je vous
dirais même que l'année passée d'année
dernière
c'est des gens qui viennent dans nos
familles on a eu un conflit qui vivent
en amérique
françois colombet se fournit chez
ludovic audouard spécialiste des
décorations lumineuses pour les
municipalités et les professionnels mais
pour son ami il fait une exception lui
remet le photo un regard d'enfant
d'abord parce que tout peut avoir
françois colombet ne se renouvelle pas
tous les ans mais parfois la facture
peut grimper jusqu'à 2000 euros
un investissement qui le place presque
auront des animations officiel de la
commune
ça se sait très bien dans la vallée ils
ont circulé viennent voir avec plaisir
que cette décoration assez ce sont des
genres de l'animation qui nous plaisent
bien et que les gens ont envie de vivre
de plus en plus le maire de lormes
pourrait bien donner un coup de pouce à
françois colombet pour les prochaines
éditions
une chose est sûre ici c'est un peu plus
le père noël nous partons pour la corse
maintenant avec une idée pour vos
cadeaux faits maison la boutique atelier
instant création met à l'honneur la
récupération et l'imagination
c'est l'idée de cet atelier transmettre
un savoir faire et favoriser la création
plutôt que des achats aseptisé sur
amazon le commerce de proximité la
relation clients font partie des
arguments de cet établissement qui tient
autant au commerce qu'à la formation
un reportage à l'île rousse de nos
confrères devient telle est pas aisé sur
place le concept de départ c'est le
créer un lieu de création pour tout le
monde
enfants et adultes et avoir un lieu de
partage autour de la création
c'est un lieu de vie pour nous donc on
l'a conçu avec un espace boutique
et puis cet espace dans lequel on se
trouve de l'atelier qu'est ce que vous
faites dans cette boutique on fait de la
vente
évidemment de tout ce qui est matériel
de beaux-arts les arts graphiques et
puis les loisirs créatifs je suis
architecte d'intérieur de métier la déco
ça c'est mon truc je suis tombé dedans
très tôt et puis j'ai toujours aimé
aussi créé de mes mains et je pense que
c'est un épanouissement personnel et
pour tout le monde et aussi c'est un
lieu des changes
votre atelier c'est aussi une façon d'un
peu de transmettre ce fait main j'aime
beaucoup l'entouré d'enfants et même
d'adultes qui ont la même passion que
moi
il chauffe que l'éveil artistique des
enfants c'est beau à voir quoi ces bois
vivre moi j'aime bien faire toucher à
tout n'a pu faire des tableaux sur le
thème de la mer on a fait
et un peu de couture avec un sac pliage
pour aller faire les courses
on peut faire de la résine pour
expérimenter un petit peu ce que ce que
ça fait le coulage dans des moules ça
fait quelques temps maintenant qu'il ya
cette tendance du diois on appelle le
fait maison comment vous pouvez
l'expliquer c'est peut-être un contre un
contre courant de tout ce qui est
numérique
et puis il ya aussi tout le côté récup
qu'est ce que vous voulez mettre en
valeur dans cette boutique c'est un peu
la caverne d'ali baba et moi ce que
j'aime aussi dans ma boutique c'est
apporter beaucoup de conseils ces salles
avantages d'un commerce de proximité
c'est le conseil sinon bah sinon bah sur
amazon c'est pour ça qu'on existe je
suis une passionnée de ce que de tout ce
qui est créatif en fait donc j'aime bien
le transmettre au juge que c'est
chouette
bonjour guy fischer merci d'être
l'invitée du grand jt des territoires en
duplex de tours vous avez écrit un livre
et c'est pour ça vous êtes avec nous
aujourd'hui chez food édition ce livre
s'appelle sans marque culte label france
et bien c'est l'histoire de l'apéritif
du bonnet ou des cachous lajaunie ou
bien des deux chevaux ou bien du be bop
ou du minitel toutes ces marques qui ont
fait la france avec souvent une certaine
nostalgie
alors pourquoi cette idée de livre
comment cela vous est-il venu lyon
fischer ont fait l'idée de ce livre
c'était de rendre hommage on fait au
savoir-faire français ou qui depuis 1850
ont inventé des marques absolument
géniale du canot pneumatique zodiac à la
4l renault on va la fêter un petit peu
un hommage au savoir-faire français
cyril au fond guillon fischer il s'agit
du made in france avant que ce soit à la
mode
alors effectivement le lean france qui
est revenu en grâce avec le locaux vides
et à crise sanitaire
ces marques montre bien que le concept
existe depuis depuis des décennies alors
on le voit dans ce livre des marques ont
totalement disparu et puis d'autres sont
toujours bien
vivace comment vous expliquez que
certaines sont encore présents dans
notre quotidien et d'autre et bien on ne
voit plus du tout une marque pour
qu'elle soit résiliente et qu'elle reste
elle doit réussir à passer l'air du
temps alors cette fois en termes de
design ce soit en terme de technique
pour passer les siècles
il doit y avoir également la qualité de
la marque la remise en cause le
renouvellement est celle qui
effectivement ont disparu souvent elles
ont été victimes un petit peu pas
d'archaïsme met enfin en tout cas
d'immobilisme
merci guillaume fischer je rappelle que
vous avez écrit ce livre avec raphaël
turcat rédacteur en chef notamment dû
magazine technikart qui est votre co
auteur pour ce livre sans marque culte
label france chez les éditions food food
édition un excellent cadeau par ailleurs
pour les fêtes
merci beaucoup cyril à cette belle
histoire maintenant qui pourrait être
une histoire de noël
en tout cas elle pourrait donner le
sourire à beaucoup de l'albanie à
l'occitanie voici le parcours hors du
commun de goran arrivé il y a quatre ans
sur le territoire il était considéré
comme un mineur isolé il a été pris en
charge par les services sociaux et il a
décroché une formation en apprentissage
au collège emile-alain de carcassonne et
s'illustre dans la cuisine française
cette année lui sa recette apparaissent
dans le livre d'agri locale un guide qui
met en avant les produits locaux à
rayonnement international
son histoire est racontée par les
équipes de vieux occitanie sur place
regarder
comme chaque mercredi à l'heure du repas
le réfectoire du collège emile-alain à
carcassonne évident pourtant on cuisine
on s'active le chef cuistot jean jacques
et ses trois employés s'apprêtent à
faire un exercice de dressage de plat le
principal intéressé s'est lui julian
il a 20 ans il est un apprentissage dans
cet établissement depuis trois ans
pourtant rien ne prédestinait ce jeune
albanais à être ici aujourd'hui je suis
arrivé en france en 2016 j'avais 16 ans
et demi ça se passerait pas trop bien
avec la faille
du coup je me suis barré arrivée en
france
l'adolescent obtient le statut de
mineurs non accompagnés
un statut dont bénéficie automatiquement
les mineurs étrangers isolés présents
sur le territoire
prise en charge par un service de l'aide
sociale à l'enfance il finit par
atterrir à carcassonne tu arrivé j'étais
accueil par conseil départemental de
l'aude
après on me proposait un contrat
informations de cuisine j'ai fait un
moins de stages au collège de bram et le
chef de bram
il m'a proposé un contrat
d'apprentissage je ne suis pas arrêté
maintenant je vais en poney délicatement
sur glace julien obtient alors un statut
de travailleur indépendant
un parcours exceptionnel et qui ne
s'arrête pas là cette année un de ses
plats été sélectionné pour figurer dans
le livre de recettes d'agri locale une
plateforme qui promeut les produits
locaux
ils gagnent grâce aux thèses qui
prêchent un plat traditionnel albanais
c'est surtout cette configuration je
dirais d'adaptation d'un produit
albanais et d'une recette albanaise à la
sauce audoise à médina pays cathare et
donc ça c'est quelque chose qui a
fortement interpellé le jury national
une recette albanaise avec des produits
audois finalement ce plat c'est un peu
l'histoire de julian celle d'une
intégration réussie
prenons de la hauteur direction la tête
de chien à la turbie où un hélicoptère
est intervenue il ya quelques jours et
ce pour les besoins de travaux de
consolidation d'une falaise à proximité
ce sont des images de nos confrères sur
place de monaco info à reportage de
sandrine des grès
d'alexandra paolini et nous sommes à
quelques pas de l'observatoire situé à
la turbie ici le panorama est magnifique
une vue imprenable sur la principauté
c'est aussi l'endroit qui a été choisi
pour permettre à cet hélicoptère de se
poser une opération délicate
la participation de cet hélicoptère une
condition sine qua non alors aujourd'hui
ont été réalisées les opérations de
délits portage pour pouvoir amener le
matériel nécessaire donc aux travaux de
réhabilitation des comportements dont
condé confortement existants de la
falaise du bout du gant
on actuellement sur la tête de chien et
une centaine de mètres en contrebas on
va trouver la falaise du mot tuant donc
falaise qui domine à la fois la moyenne
corniche et la sortie du tunnel du
tunnel rainier iii donc le tunnel qui
assure la liaison entre monaco et la
france dans le sens sortant une falaise
qui dans les années 90 a été équipée de
soixante deux ouvrages de confortement
pour prévenir les chutes de pierres et
maintenir ainsi la sécurité sur la
moyenne corniche et d'ici la fin de
l'année on va commencer à conforter
certains blocs c'est à dire on va fort
et on va poser des câbles efforts et les
rochers en profondeur pourrait enfiler
des bars qu'on appelle les des crayons
les boulons dans le cross sont
débarrassés longue entre quatre et cinq
mètres pour stabiliser ces anciens
ancrage qui sont maintenant trop vieux
quatre anciens et ensuite en janvier on
va transporter un autre compresseur
beaucoup plus gros qui va nous permettre
avec une autre machine qui est bien plus
grosse que celle qu'on va utiliser
maintenant qui est maintenant c'est un
thé 21 ça s'appelle un espèce de marteau
piqueur mais auquel on rallonge des
tiges pour forer la roche et tandis
qu'en janvier on va voir un autre
une autre machine qui elle va fort et
plus profondes et qui permettra ainsi la
pose de barres de plus gros diamètre
nous suivrons d'ailleurs cette étape
afin de mesurer la dimension acrobatique
de ce type de travaux nous partons
maintenant dans la rubrique écorégions
pour la charente-maritime dans son jt
des territoires à la rencontre d'une
société qui s'appelle sharks industries
une société spécialisée dans les robots
industriels
michel picaud bonjour vous nous en dit
plus sur cette pme très made in france
qui commence à rayonner dans le monde et
même jusque dans l'espace
bonjour cyril bonjour à toutes et à tous
shark robotics a été créé en 2016 ils
sont installés à deux pas de la rochelle
c'est là qu'ils fabriquent entièrement
leurs robots industriels jusqu'à la
batterie mission de leur robot éloigné
l'homme des zones à risques on les
trouve donc dans les domaines de la
sécurité de la défense de l'industrie de
l'énergie et dû nucléaire est plus
surprenant en 2016 lors de l' incendie
de notre dame de paris
c'est leur robot pompiers qui est entré
seul dans le monument flammes où la
température a atteint les 800 degrés 10
heures d'intervention pour son robot qui
ont permis notamment d'éviter
l'effondrement de la cathédrale et de
sauvegarder de nombreuses oeuvres d'art
grâce aux frappes chirurgicales du robot
à savoir la détection rapide des points
chauds avec sa caméra thermique et du
refroidissement avec un canon à eau et
le robot est ressorti intacte en 2020 il
décide d'adapter leurs robots pour enfin
en robot de décontamination capable de
micro pulvériser des solutions
désinfectantes sur vingt mille mètres
carrés de surface en seulement trois
heures enfin et ce n'est pas fini la pme
française a été contacté par l'américain
boston dynamics et leader incontesté de
la robotique mondial pour un partenariat
technologique toujours dans le cadre de
la lutte contre la copie de 19 et shark
robotics 40 personnes a donc fait son
entrée sur le marché américain et
envisage désormais d'envoyer certains de
ces robots pour des missions dans
l'espace
qui a dit que nous n'avions pas des
talents dans le territoire merci michel
picaud nous vous retrouvons dans une
prochaine édition du grand jt des
territoires pour nous présenter des
entreprises qui font rayonner le savoir
faire français
c'est un véritable trésor que nous
allons vous présenter maintenant un
véritable trésor caché
le manoir de verdi nier à avesnes en
saosnois dans la sarthe
ces bâtiments qui tombait en ruines sont
restaurés par deux frères propriétaires
des lieux
récemment d'ailleurs le toit du manoir a
été reconstruit à l'identique vous allez
le voir il est d'une forme très rare un
dôme impériale qui a valu au maître
charpentier qui l'a restitué d'être
lauréat national du concours ateliers
d'art de france
un reportage d'hélène à galiana sur
place pour vyas lmtv sarthe
[Musique]
le manoir de verdi nier est niché au
fond d'un long chemin de terre encore
protégé par ses douves l'édifice trône
ici depuis plus de 100 ans
une des caractéristiques de cet ensemble
c'est un signe fortifiée avec une
architecture de philibert delorme
c'est donc un site très très intéressant
au point de vue culturel
[Musique]
car imaginer à l'époque ses parents pour
le vie que l'on pénétrait à l'intérieur
du site
et si l'on n'était pas invité c'étaient
les meurtrières qui se chargeait de
l'accueil
le site abandonné plusieurs décennies
est en travaux depuis bientôt 14 ans une
restauration longue mené par stéphane
leroux il a restauré à l'identique un
dôme impérial sur l'une des bâtisses
c'est un dôme à l'impérial qui a existé
que l'on l'a restitué grasset une une
photo d'un historien damien castel qui a
retrouvé ce document là bizarrement une
photo de 1890 sur lequel il y avait
encore ce dôme et de ce fait monsieur
gagnon ont décidé de restituer ce dôme
là un ouvrage qui a permis aux
charpentiers d'être récompensée pour son
travail il est le lauréat du concours
des ateliers d'art de france ça donne un
certain plaisir de participer à
l'entretien d'un monument historique
et puis de le remettre en état pour
qu'ils repartent pour quelques centaines
d'années si les s'il est bien entretenu
il reste encore beaucoup de travail au
sens du manoir qui n'a peut-être pas
encore livré tous ses secrets
pour les curieux les propriétaires des
lieux organise des visites sur demande
[Musique]
voilà noël c'est aussi parfois le moment
de rêver un peu nous partons à lorient
pour un voyage long cours qui va vous
faire rêver la goélette scientifique
tara a largué les amarres et pendant
deux ans eh bien elle va voguer dans
l'atlantique sud pour étudier les fonds
marins afin de nous en dire un peu plus
sur notre passé mais aussi sur notre
futur un reportage des équipes de tébéo
sur place en bretagne
tara à nouveau en expédition depuis son
port d'attache de lorient la goélette
scientifique est partie pour un périple
de 70 kilomètres au programme un tour
complet des mers et littoraux d'amérique
du sud et une remontée le long des côtes
ouest de l'afrique
les 80 scientifiques qui se relaieront à
bord vont étudier en détail le
microbiome marin mais qu'est ce que ce
fameux microbiome on a l'habitude de
voir des gros organismes des animaux des
plantes
mais dans tous les écosystèmes que ce
soit le séant ou le désert ou n'importe
quoi il ya toute une toute une partie de
l'écosystème qu'on voit pas qui est
invisible qui est le microbiome cse tous
les organismes plus petit qu'à peu près
1 mm donc ce sont essentiellement des
organismes unicellulaires comme les
virus les bactéries les arcs et des
cellules plus complexes comme une autre
mais à l'état unicellulaires tous ces
organismes sous marins microscopiques
produisent 50% de l'oxygène sur terre
leur étude précis sur les différents
lieux de la planète va permettre de
mesurer leur état de santé et du coup
celui du monde on va comprendre en fait
comment l'écosystème océan peut résister
ou s'effondrer par rapport à des
changements climatiques on va comprendre
jusqu'où on peut aller en fait les unes
les barrières qu'on ne devrait pas
dépasser pour maintenir un océan en
bonne santé et une planète habitable
c'est passionnant par définition parce
que c'est le monde de l'invisible
surtout c'est de voir un peu qu'elle
impacte donc vont avoir les
réchauffements quel impact à la
pollution aux micro plastiques notamment
sur ce micro guillaume qui a un rôle
essentiel à jouer sur internet
après son retour à lorient dans un an et
demi deux ans il faudra encore patienter
pour analyser les échantillons
microscopique récoltés et ans à voir
donc beaucoup plus sur l'état de notre
planète
peut-être larmes du futur pour venir à
bout de lakovic 19 son nom eut mana et
elle nous vient de bretagne c'est une
peinture de revêtements intérieurs anti
bactérienne qui a été testé contre le
coronavirus et les résultats sont tombés
90% du virus serait détruit en trois
minutes un peu comme le gel
hydroalcoolique que nous mettons sur nos
mains direction les côtes d'armor pour
tous les détails avec nos partenaires de
tvr sur place à rennes
avec son siège social installé à saint
pern en ille et vilaine et ses ateliers
à plouasne dans les côtes d'armor la
société armor habitat distribuer en
france depuis onze ans une peinture de
revêtements intérieurs antibactérienne
fabriqués en italie à l'aune du comique
19 le produit a été testé en laboratoire
en y déposant la souche du coronavirus
le résultat est tombé au mois d'octobre
le laboratoire en fait indique dans les
trois premières minutes 90 % de l'adn du
virus est détruit et dans les 15
premières minutes 100% de l'adn et
détruit donc il ne reste plus rien au
bout de 15 minutes
ce qui veut dire que l'on a un effet
actif très important et que l'on à
l'identique des gels hydro-alcooliques
on peut dire que l'on est là dans une
réduction de la transmission du virus
par loi de contacts dans tous les lieux
publics dans tout les salles d'attenté
des médecins ou des professions
libérales dans les hôpitaux les ehpad
les écoles les crèches bien évidemment
cette peinture peut avoir un effet très
intéressant sur la propagation du virus
pour obtenir de tels résultats le
principe actif de cette peinture
intitulé human à est protégé par un
brevet qui intègre des nanomatériaux
infiniment petit car les produits actifs
contenus dans la peinture qui vont tuer
effectivement ces virus sont issus d'une
réaction avec des matières qui sont
plutôt des matières minérales qui vont
réagir avec la lumière donc la lumière
ces sont des produits ce qu'on appelle
photocatalytiques un petit peu comme
certains composants électroniques
aujourd'hui peuvent réagir en produisant
de l'électricité avec de la lumière
comme les panneaux photovoltaïques
désormais doté de l'étiquette antique
vide du mana est en vente à destination
des professionnels depuis trois semaines
la société armor habitat et son enseigne
arnaud 10 à l'exclusivité de sa
distribution sur le marché français pour
ceux d'entre vous qui aiment les visites
et les excursions et bien si vous vous
promeniez dans une ville avec toutes les
archives en poche
c'est ce que vous propose ce reportage
alors imaginez vous en bretagne dans la
ville de rennes et découvrez
des images d'archivés d'histoires
inédites de la commune grâce à une appli
qui est avec vous pour tout savoir et
pour tout comprendre
voici les détails avec nos confrères sur
place de thé vert à rennes archives en
poche c'est la nouvelle application qui
permet de découvrir reine à travers des
films amateurs le concept propose de
visionner des images inédites
directement sur son smartphone grâce à
la géolocalisation pour l'instant une
quinzaine d'archives/reuters sur
l'application
on attend qu'elle terrain ou alors sur
les chemins de l'école en faisant ses
courses on se dit tiens il ya peut-être
quelque chose à découvrir par ici on
regarde il ya un point d'intérêt juste à
côté et on redécouvre la petite ou la
grande histoire
la crue de la vilaine en 1966 la
libération de rennes en 1944 ces films
argentiques inédits sont issus des fonds
de la cinémathèque de bretagne
c'est une manière de rendre hommage
aussi à des hommes et des femmes
qui à leur manière avec les moyens du
bord ont capté des moments qui sont
entrés dans la postérité des moments
qu'ils ont tourné souvent innocemment
sans se dire qu'un jour ces images
seraient conservés documenté et
valoriser pour que le plus grand nombre
en 2020 puis s'en emparer rennes sert de
ville pilote pour le lancement de
l'application si le concept trouve son
public
archives en poche pourrait être décliné
dans d'autres petites et grandes
communes bretonnes voit la fin de cette
édition spéciale nouvelle année du grand
jt des territoires nous vous souhaitons
toute l'équipe du grand jt une
excellente belle et heureuse année et à
très vite sur vos chaînes locales et
régionales et sur tv5 monde
bonne année à tous
[Musique]